Oui oui : c'est "accidentogène" parce qu'en fait
a des toutes petites voiles et du coup
on acquiert beaucoup de vitesse on est à peu près à
150 km/h sur trajectoire donc en fait on n'a pas le
droit à l'erreur on doit toucher l'eau on
n'est plus à 150 km/h mais on est à 130/140
donc toucher l'eau à 130 km/h si on
se rate d'1 mètre on peut taper fort l'eau
et ricocher et du coup se blesser. Après, vous avez
vu, on va à plus de 100 mètres après avoir
touché l'eau on est quand même à une vitesse
qui diminue mais on peut toucher assez fort
le sol donc c'est vrai que c'est "accidentogène"
après c'est une discipline qui demande beaucoup d'expérience
il n'y a pas de place pour les
débutants on a tous plusieurs milliers de sauts
voire dizaines de milliers de sauts
c'est ce qui nous permet de pouvoir faire
une discipline assez particulière, assez
technique.